C'était un moment deébébébration
pour Celsius Network: en octobre
2021, la Caisse de dépôt et
placement du Québec annonçait
avoir misé plus e e e centaine
de millions de dollars sur la
compagnie qui offre des services
de prêts en cryptomonnaie.
Celsius set t t une solution
de rechange aux banques
conventionnelles. Comme dans
un compte épargne, les clients
pet t t y déposer leurs crypto
monnaie et obtenir un rendement
sur leurs dépôts. Ils peuvent
aussi emprunter des crypto
monnaies.
Pour la CDPQ. Ce partenaire
représentait l'avenir du monde
financier. La technologie
des chaînes de blocs présente
un potentiel perturbateur pour
plusieurs secteurs de l'économie
traditionnellevavavavait alors
Alexandre Synett, premier vice
président et chef des
technologies de la CDPQ.
Mais ce potentiel perturbateur
fait sleleleler plusieurs
experts du domaine, qui jugent
que certaines activités de
la compagnie sont très risquées.
Autrement dit, les clients
de Celsius prennent le risque
de tout perdre et lors du krach,
du 11 mai, où 200 milliards
de dollars se sont évaporés
du monde de la crypto. C'est
exactement ce que plusieurs
d'utilisateurs de Celsius disent
avoir vécu. Sur les réseaux
sociaux, ils écrivaient que la
crypto qu'ils avaient déposé
chez Celsius pour obtenir
des prêts avait été liquidée.
La méthode Celsius inquiète nos
voisins du Sud. Dans la dernière
année, cinq États américains ont
envoyé des mises en garde
à l'entreprise, la sommant
de cesser des activités jugées
comme étant illégales.
Certains de ces avis précèdent
l'investissement de la CDPQ.
Celsius conteste le bien fondé
de ces avis, mais à cesser
d'offrir aux Américains certains
services. En mars 2022,
le département du Travail
des États-Unis a publié un avis
t t t t t t t fortement
aux fonds de retraite américains
d'investir dans l'univers
des crypto monnaies. Au Canada,
les autorités ont peu à dire sur
leur surveillanceueueueueueueu.
Pourtant, le ministère fédéral
des Finances nous confirme qu'en
général, ce type d'entreprise
non enregistrée agit danslélélée
Celsius, qui offre ses services
financiers aux Canadiens
sans être inscrite auprès des
autorités financières du pays.
Dans un courriel, une porte
parole de la CDPQ nous a écrit
que les investissements de
la Caisse font l'objet d'un
processus d'analyse rigoureux.
Elle ajoute que Celsius est
favorable à la réglementation
et que la CDPQ compte avoir
une influence positive sur c
processus. Le PDG de Celsius,
de son côté, nous a écrit que
la société collabore avec
les autorités afin de rendre
l'entreprise conforme aux
exigences des régulateurs.
Brigitte Noël,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.